[Music]
in good [ __ ] news hmm submitted by the
Zoe and Maya though oh you didn't know
the name and will urge the kiss [ __ ]
this I am too getting the [ __ ] out of
her cat's a parasite found in cat poop
and raw meat is a link to a reduced fear
of failure in humans wait one more time
why someone's stealing my tissue paper
pregnant women a pair saw Paris out Oh
a parasite found in cat poop and Romney
is linked to a reduced fear of failure
in humans what yep
that means that parasite affects
something in the brain where reduces
that part that doesn't make you scared
do [ __ ] but skip being scared is a good
thing I rather eat red meat than cat
[ __ ] though yeah yeah good call dude
good call I don't think the article is
advocating yeah one more time my brains
not processing it what are you what did
you hear I want to hear what hear what
did you hear I heard parasites and
pregnant women between there's a parent
to my [ __ ] marriage I was so
interesting this is one out of a
thousand articles I didn't understand
this is true that's a good yeah what a
million articles maybe that's right what
yeah it's mainly this guy that well this
standard is pretty low so the fact that
she's comparing you to him if she was
like yeah this guy or to me then I'd
give it to you but you're still losing
no I'm listening more than a less than
one that's got to I choose not to listen
thank you very much I have to repeat
myself
laughing it I never present all right
there's bit creams have a sale bar let
me tell you okay so there's this
parasite that's found in cat poop yeah
and also raw meat
that is now linked to having this effect
on people's brains where they have no
like they have reduced it fear oh I need
that for Heights and [ __ ] yeah do they
do the office in a pill form
I wondered me to choose the reduced fear
like the percentage not mean like what
type of fear you can reduce the fear on
yeah like if I'm like maybe before I go
on a roller coaster I take yeah because
I have you become fearless on things
that you probably should be fearful of
yeah that's I'm sick babes I'm driving
Hosting something that's gonna ruin your
career and they're like should I cause
give a book take it I just and he
[ __ ] pull some [ __ ] pedophile
judge assumption your whole career yeah
you go on YouTube and said you met Drake
oh my god that was the funniest
explanation of his meeting I saw him he
was four feet away I was like that's not
he looked at me damn bill brought a deal
the funny it's funny but it's at the
same time cuz you know he does have
issues but he said he's like I wanted to
speak into existence so [ __ ] adorable
yeah so they found that a lot of it
entrepreneurs the people are a bit who
are interested in business they had at
one point contracted this parasite so
I've been [ __ ] fumbling to attach it
you eat a lot of red meat oh yeah oh
that means we got that [ __ ] at a [ __ ]
young age because we were sound like a
bunch of [ __ ] as little kids Oh what did
you sell uh so I would go to Costco and
buy candy in bulk and then at school I
would yep I would sell it and then I
also had like garage sales and [ __ ]
garage sales are there [ __ ] dude
i priced all my own [ __ ] I was like by
myself no parents I set up my little
table and I had all my items mostly but
I was selling drugs yeah
and runs on a vegetarian diet oh yeah
then what happened yes I didn't get red
meat I didn't get red meat until I moved
in with my dad well my parents my mom is
vegetarian and I'll selling drugs you're
eating [ __ ] weren't you only two ways
human could get this red meat or dishes
or cat6 those [ __ ] cats man you
[ __ ] cat diddler yeah so this thing
is called textile plasma gondii parasite
gondii parasite I mean the gon so
benevolent Oh Andy what about Gandy sure
you are saying that this it has been
linked to a greater risk of car
accidents mental illness and neuroticism
drug abuse and suicide all of those
except for car accident BAM that's true
that's me
my suicide dude I tried though I wanted
to we talked about this all of us try it
out I didn't try you tried it I did so
many so I was so self-destructive I
might as well be you know but then I
know I never tried try like that I I
thought I thought I thought it but it
didn't exist I'm too much of a [ __ ] to
try to kill myself dude I didn't think
it into existence enough that's what
happened you gotta speak it into
existence
yeah yeah I didn't speak it into
existence I think that's [ __ ] true
though yeah yeah yeah and I but you know
what I'm a safe driver
not really I'm reckless as your face and
I'm unlucky
okay I'm [ __ ] lucky driver all right
like I'm a lucky driver you're like a
podcast featuring yourself plays both
sides I'm editing live guys you don't
need bog dude because my brain works so
[ __ ] fast that it hit me like no I
shouldn't say something that isn't true
I'm gonna correct myself I play does
it sounds like you're malfunctioning
more than thinking really fast
and it sounds like multiple personality
disorder little bit would you say Jeff I
know no I didn't mean it that way
multiple personalities now you don't
have yourself correcting yourself and
the other person correcting yourself I
usually try and do it before internal
monologue it doesn't usually go external
yeah that disgust you doing here well
I'm an open book and I'm not afraid to
tell the truth that's what it is you've
got to go open book Joe is just a blank
notebook man with a bunch of scribbles
in it that's what you think I really all
right so then this professor of
management at the University of Colorado
and her husband who's a professor of
biology at that same university they
found [ __ ] high as professors they
were both they decided like team up and
find out what this parasite really does
to the brain so what they did is they
gave saliva tests for antibodies to tack
so plasm to nearly 1,500 students and
nearly 200 people attending seminars on
how to start your own business and they
found that 22 percent of the people that
they tested did have nmi ana antibodies
to that parasite which means that they
had been infected at some point so they
were saying that this somehow is linked
to them not having fears of starting
because you have to be fearless to me
yes you know for stupidest fun yeah yes
which also is fearless do so um you know
what's really interesting is I recently
watched this documentary about parasites
controlling your mood controlling your
like what you want and whatever because
you know in our gut they call it the
second brain and I don't know how real
science this is because you know there's
the pseudoscience and then there's the
real science right but this is sounding
along the lines of what I saw it's more
like so in our gut we have
sites that help break down certain
things so let's say if we eat a lot of
pork or a lot of meat then a lot of that
parasite will start growing because you
know they need to go down to help break
down the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] in your gut and if you're not
all of a sudden having that then it's
like we gotta [ __ ] get this guy to
kill something so he could eat the red
meat and it just sent signals on in your
brain to do some [ __ ] yeah so there's a
lot of there's a lot of [ __ ] going in
there like probiotics do you think that
would stand in court if we're like let
me do it you guys think you can go vegan
vegetarian I was pretty close to vegan I
know I could do yeah [ __ ] yeah really
yeah easy look you know how much I love
candy when I was pregnant I cut that
[ __ ] out completely like cold turkey she
did hmm yes good this yeah I think well
cause she doesn't like food that much
but I love candy I love candy so for me
to cut that cool Turkey I think it's
like a crackhead quitting crack [ __ ]
I got he read me at least every other
day oh really
least dang I live off red meat dude if I
don't have red meat you think so but the
old one never mind like animal products
like milk and you're like cheese is
amazing milk if I use like um you become
so desperate and you want it so bad that
like the the faux version of it you're
just like alright this will do like it's
never like the what you remember it to
be but you start forgetting I will say
this though I've been eating at Buddhist
vegetarian fitness joints those are balm
I'll go even and I'll be [ __ ]
beginner for a whole year if they've got
it down yeah I mean it's that [ __ ]
guy's really good I can't make it home
though it also means like leather
products products so your car you can't
have us I just tell my food and ice oh
that's just bomb but like if I only eat
like let say fish and chicken or
something like that you know what the
best seasoning um I feel like I've been
starving for a week if I don't get mad
me what do you like what me so much in
figure Paris I didn't I bet you he does
yeah yeah that's weird cuz I don't I I
could I'll have a steak maybe once every
like month or two months yeah but I
don't know I don't need to eat red meat
like that's like I do is it's not a
steak for me though like I'll crave like
burgers yeah like a burger shabu shabu
that'd be like a like a fancy steak oh
go ahead meat like if I want a burger
right and they said like all you could
eat is like a fish burger or salmon
burger I'm good
Oh for me I'm like that's like me uh
taking three breaths of air and I gotta
get a real meal later on that's like me
drinking some water when I really want
to coke
yeah when I have a craving that [ __ ] is
on my mind forever man it just [ __ ]
bugs me every day it just itches at me
like you need to do it one time have you
have you had those Vietnamese egg
noodles or it's like Vietnamese Chinese
dry noodle
oh [ __ ] right so I was thinking about it
on Thursday Friday I was like I don't
need to go it's in the OSI is too far
Saturday comes along alright maybe I'll
go to Sam Wu and I'll get some duck with
rice and that could that could do it for
me and that just made me go one even
more exactly yeah it was like Sunday I'm
going to the OC to get [ __ ] dry
noodle so I drove an hour away just to
get it but my excuse was I'm taking the
dogs to the dog beach so I used them
just again that was the main reason did
you make it to the dog beach yeah should
I forgot the dog so clean this time yeah
it was crazy
[Music]
[Music]